value does more bodies bring to a guy
does it have to bring value yeah no I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying when when a
girl Banner biologically predisposition
to be attracted to Purity and youth what
do you mean by that like all throughout
throughout all of history like the most
powerful men had concubines of virgins
right but like so so that's something
yeah
I'm saying you can't I'm saying Genghis
Khan yeah but I would attribute that to
the claiming of power
voters
I would say that would be attributed to
men wanting or people in those positions
one is claiming as much power as
possible and the more most power you can
have is over a submissive pure female
right it doesn't necessarily right but
I'm saying like we're they're attracted
to Youth and Purity and they can't undo
that but that's that's a power based
mindset right and that power is what we
kind of crave through a survival mindset
right when we're trying the person who
has the most power is the most likely to
survive right and so when we're in that
frame of mind that makes sense but
that's not the world that we kind of
really live in more it's not really
based around survival it's not based
around this calling for power I don't
think that should be the
um
the defining factor in terms of right
but that's like a woman's point of view
you might you might not think that but
in general guys care and so it's like
you can't go to the market and tell them
and I know I know your friend doesn't
and like like but this is an exception
but it's not the rules he's that much of
an exception I've met a lot of people
who don't really care and don't really
consider that because there are other
factors they consider they're trying to
sleep with you who like the people that
told you that in terms of they don't
care
those guys are here right so guys you
prefer a purer woman than more of a hoe
absolutely yeah and there's a lot of
factors when it comes to liking a girl
but I think if the exact same girl and
then she slept with a thousand men or
three men it's like um yeah I don't
judge the girl that slept with them live
your life but yeah you're gonna want the
girl who has had less men inside of her
right even if even if I were to say that
there was any weight on body count I
would say you'd have to consider that
the circumstances that that body count
happened in right where that person was
at why they were sleeping around right
and what space they'd might be in right
I don't think that's true I don't
believe that's true I think that is
actually kind of making too much of a
generalization I know you work on the
job
but that is too much it's it's a lot
more nuanced than that I don't think as
many men as you think actually so I'm
just saying if a woman came to me and
said I've slept with a thousand men
because I was broken and I had been
abused and blah blah blah right you
still slept with a thousand men where's
the compassion in that though where's
where's that's what I'm not thinking
about I'm thinking about you've had a
thousand penises inside you are going to
be with someone shouldn't compassion be
a main factor in that relationship right
an understanding of who they are of what
they've been through shouldn't that be
amazing
yeah the world doesn't owe you
understanding like that's entitlementing
you're not you're not entitled to
someone's compassion and understanding
and that I think men are allowed to be
selective in who they date and like I
think men are allowed to have standards
and if that's their standard so be it
and it's not it's not every single guy
but I think in general if you pull men
would you rather have a girl that stuff
up with a hundred or slept with one they
would pick one and and I are they less
picky than they were a hundred years ago
sure you were a hoe If you slept with
three people a hundred years ago right
right so are they less picky now sure
but you can't undo the wiring What What
In general men want
so where would you say that's come from
in terms of them wanting that where
would you because
I'll tell you where is that so
historically historically they had to
ensure paternity so historically like a
man a man did not want to pass on
resources to a kid that was not theirs
so they're biologically predispositioned
to be grossed out by hoes you know
basically yeah because it's like well
whose child is that it's not mine it
could be like it could be Stanley's and
Derrick's do you know I mean he doesn't
know and so
you're trying to I hear what you're
saying but you can't undo the biological
wiring that human beings have had for
centuries thousands of years it just is
what it is can we can we put a marker on
where this historic number is coming
from you're saying 100 years ago that
was 1922. so okay so like maybe
so between can you speak into the
microphone please sorry between World
War one and World War II and in what
part like like you it's a very it's a
very vague argument you're saying you're
saying historically a hundred years ago
you could you could take um data from
like the 1950s where the majority of
high school graduates were actually
virgins before like the whole set birth
control was introduced in the sexual
Revolution like happen in the U.S
because so that was wasn't actually
invented by then like yeah you're right
like I'm not saying like women a women
it gave women the option to sleep around
but that's what I'm saying back then it
was like um it was bad like it was
looked down upon if you had more than a
certain amount of sex partners and you
can even think of this anecdotally like
if I start telling my mom about that if
I start telling my mom about the body
counts like of girls nowadays she's
disgusted she's like what on Earth is
going on I tell my grandma I tell I tell
my grandma but that's
I tell my grandma about like the body
counts nowadays she's like what is going
on in these streets and we could just
say like anecdotally and me when I hear
like my little sister with the stories
that they tell me I'm like what on Earth
but it's like every generation go ahead
in America right now uh
100 of women that enter the college
system run 17 right only 12.3 lead
virgins
only 12.3 lead for college virgins wait
you give me an a hundred percent you've
got 100 women entering the college
education system and when you leave the
college education system only 12.3
percent of virgins what's that statistic
for men
for women so what's that statistic for
men though 4.4.5 4.5 liver men leave
virgins and 12. sorry 14.5 14 points and
12.5 12. 12.3 so we're talking a
difference of like one and a half two
percent so so what happens during the
College Years now in in these days and
times is people are definitely more
promiscuous in the most formative years
of their life when they're supposed to
be going out and experiencing new
experiences so so okay so then we have
this whole it's a misnomer though right
it's completely so do you do you think
Society benefits from promiscuity or it
doesn't benefit from promiscuity I think
it's completely irrelevant do you think
promiscuity is completely irrelevant I
think whether it benefits Society or not
is irrelevant I don't think like you're
I don't think that it should be a
definitive enough as like one person 100
people 1 000 people it is a benefit or
not to society you can't prescribe
statistics yeah it's just like you can't
we go on 12.4 of this because it's it's
relevant subjective to each individual
individual and their own bodily autonomy
okay but do you do you think it's do you
think it's good for families that people
are sleeping around more
in what sense like do you think it's
good to go into a marriage with a bunch
of exes
is that is that good like and I just say
this from from experience because my
parents have only been with each other
and like where I would see you know Exes
come back in the picture and like some
of my friends parents marriages and like
other stuff come in where my parents had
like only been with each other and I
think it was better for their marriage
and that's completely subjective you
it's completely it's it's well you could
say that but when you also have data to
back it up right I would say there's
other factors that go into that and I
kind of bring back what I said about
them having a certain amount of
self-awareness right when you choose to
go into marriage I think people have to
take accountability for their pasts and
acknowledge you know where they're maybe
still holding on to things before you
enter into a big commitment like that
and I don't think you know the number of
your body count or the number of people
you've been with prevents you from being
able to do that I feel like you can
still make the choice to do that you
have to make the choice to do that but I
think it's independent of your body
count and I think even if you slept with
a number of people if you have the
self-awareness to be able to say this is
what I'm still holding on to these are
the people I'm still holding on to this
is why it didn't work out I'm choosing
to move forward with that that's a
choice and you can actively make that
choice consciously right you're right
and that's why it's not a hundred
percent yeah but I'm saying like every
person you sleep with brings more
baggage to the next relationship you can
learn to release that baggage you know
what I mean
you can but I don't think most women do
then I think the conversation should be
about how do we when you say that people
don't owe you understanding compassion I
would actually disagree with that
because I would say at a base as humans
we owe each other understanding we
always tell their empathy we owe each
other acceptance so that we can actually
work towards the middle ground on these
issues and find a way through instead of
kind of just placing the blame and as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible